Today on "D News,"
we're focusing entirely
on grown-up stuff.
We're going to talk about how
your gastrointestinal tract
behaves in an altered pressure
environment-- airplane farts.
Her, frequent flyers,
Trace here for "D News."
Before I leave for
CES today, I posed
a question to my
"D News" fellows--
do we fart more on planes?
Responses were mixed.
But I'm here to say, I do.
If you ever meet
me on an airplane,
you're welcome to
let it fly too,
because science
says that it's OK.
Also, it's national bean day.
So this is apropos.
Let's clear the air.
Flatulence results
from the build up
and release of
gas in the bowels.
When food makes it through
the small intestine
and enters the large intestine
as an undigested mass,
the bacteria living inside
of you go to town on it.
As they digest the
food you didn't absorb,
they release gases sort
of like yeast in bread.
So your farts are
actually collected
farts of millions
of tiny bacteria.
A study in the New
Zealand Medical Journal
sniffed out the truth about
flatulence on airplanes.
The average person farts
about a dozen times a day,
but the volume of your
gas will vary depending
on the air pressure you're
living in, they say.
On the ground, at
sea level, we're
experiencing the air pressure
of all of that air above us.
This is called one atmosphere.
It's roughly 14.7 pounds
per square inch, or PSI.
Our bodies evolved to think
that 14.7 PSI is normal.
And then we put
humans on airplanes.
At altitude, airplanes
have cabin pressures
so that we don't have to
wear masks to get oxygen.
It varies depending
on the plane,
but it's usually around
11 PSI, basically
the pressure of about
7,000 feet above sea level.
This lower air
pressure is what makes
people feel bloated
on airplanes.
The gases in your body expand in
response to the lower pressure.
This includes the gas
in your large intestine,
and then boom, more
farts, or so it seems.
They're less dense, if that
makes you feel any better.
The study goes on to suggest
solutions for farting on high,
mainly you should filter
them out, using charcoal.
Charcoal is essential
for Brita water filters,
but it can also be
used to filter the air.
If charcoal was
introduced into the seats,
the researchers say,
it would go a long way
to helping passenger comfort.
Next time you're on
an airplane and have
to fart, just let it go.
Holding it in can cause stress,
it can create physical pain,
and it can damage your bowels.
Letting it go might make
you an airplane pariah,
but at least you'll
feel at ease knowing
that it's just
lower air pressure.
Thanks, science.
Be honest, though.
Do you far more on airplanes?
Tell us below, and
subscribe for more videos.
You can also sniff us out on
Facebook, Google+, or Twitter.
Thanks a lot for watching.